Worst-case running time gives us guarantees and also it sounds like it's a very big simplification,
but the thing is as long as we're still counting the number of time steps of the algorithm exactly
even worst-case running time can get pretty tricky and I'll give you one example for this.
Again, we're going to consider an algorithm that takes as input a string of length n.
What this algorithm does is given the string of length n, it counts the number of times
that the sequence ab appears in that string.
So it will iterate over the length of the string and if it finds an a, it will look if the next character is a b
and if that is the case, it will increase the counter here.
What I would like you to consider for our next quiz is what a worst case and a bust case input
for that algorithm would look like.
Here we have the number of potential inputs and it doesn't really matter how long those inputs are.
It's more about their structure and if the structure would cause the algorithm to behave
as it would in the worst case or in the best case or something else,
and what I would like you to do is for each of those strings, tell me if that string will cause the algorithm
to go into a worst-case running time, a best-case running time, or something else.
For each of those four strings, I would like you to tell me if those strings caused the algorithm
to have the best possible running time or the worst possible running time or something in between,
and it doesn't really matter how long those strings are.
It's the structure that I want you to look at.